que dans ces situations, le courage des gens est contagieux.
Donc même si mes confrères journalistes et moi-même
étions conscients du risque -
les États-Unis sont le pays le plus puissant de la planète
et n'apprécient pas que l'on révèle leurs secrets par milliers
sur Internet à volonté,
voir une personne de 29 ans, une personne ordinaire,
qui a grandi dans un environnement tout à fait ordinaire,
faire preuve d'un courage moral aussi important que celui d'Edward Snowden,
sachant qu'il irait en prison jusqu'à sa mort
ou que sa vie s'effondrerait,
m'a inspiré, a inspiré mes confrères
et je pense, des gens du monde entier.
Même de futurs informateurs,
qui ont compris qu'ils pouvaient aussi s'engager dans de telles pratiques.
BG : J'aimerais connaître vos liens avec Ed Snowden,
car vous lui avez beaucoup parlé,
et vous continuez très certainement,
mais dans votre livre, vous ne l'appelez pas Edward,
ou Ed, vous utilisez « Snowden ». Pourquoi ?
GG : C'est certainement une chose
qui pourrait être examinée par une équipe de psychologues.
Je ne sais pas vraiment, mais il pourrait avoir une raison :
l'un de ses objectifs les plus importants,
et l'une de ses tactiques les plus importantes,
était qu'il savait qu'une manière de détourner l'attention
du contenu des révélations
serait d'essayer de diriger l'attention sur lui.
De ce fait, il s'est éloigné des médias.
Il a tenté d'éviter que sa vie privée
ne soit examinée.
Je pense que l'appeler Snowden
est une façon de le présenter comme un important acteur de l'Histoire
plutôt que de lui donner un relief particulier
qui aurait pu détourner l'attention de la véritable question.
BG : Ses révélations et le travail des journalistes
ont beaucoup nourri le débat
et plusieurs gouvernements ont réagi,
avec des projets et des programmes
pour remanier le concept d'Internet.
De nombreuses choses vont aujourd'hui dans ce sens.
Mais je voudrais savoir : vous, personnellement,
quel aboutissement souhaitez-vous ?
A quel moment penserez-vous :
« Nous avons réussi à faire bouger les choses » ?
GG : Le dénouement pour moi, en tant que journaliste,
est très simple.
Il faut qu'on soit sûr que chaque document
digne d'intérêt, digne d'être divulgué, soit divulgué,
que des secrets qui ne devraient pas l'être
soient dévoilés.
Voilà l'essence du journalisme
et voilà dans quoi je m'engage.
Comme je trouve odieuse la surveillance de masse
pour toutes les raisons que j'ai citées,
mon travail aboutira
quand les gouvernements du monde entier
ne pourront plus soumettre les populations
au contrôle et à l'espionnage
sauf s'ils convainquent un tribunal ou une entité
que la personne ciblée
a vraiment agi de façon illégale.
Voilà selon moi la façon de restaurer le droit à la vie privée.
BG : On a vu, à un événement TED,
que Snowden se présente comme un défenseur
des valeurs démocratiques et des principes démocratiques,
Pourtant, beaucoup de gens ont du mal à croire
qu'il n'avait pas d'autres motivations.
Ils ont du mal à croire
qu'il n'y avait pas d'argent en jeu,
qu'il n'a pas vendu ses secrets
à la Chine ou la Russie,
qui ne sont pas de bons amis des États-Unis en ce moment.
Je suis sûr que beaucoup de gens se posent la question :
est-il possible qu'il y ait
une facette de Snowden que nous n'avons pas encore vue ?
GG : Non, je trouve ça absurde et idiot.
(Rires)
Je sais que vous jouez juste l'avocat du diable,
mais si vous voulez vendre
des secrets à un autre pays,
ce que Snowden aurait pu faire,
et devenir très riche,
la dernière chose à faire
serait de les communiquer à la presse,
car ils perdraient toute leur valeur.
Les gens qui veulent s'enrichir
vendent leurs secrets discrètement.
Je pense qu'il est crucial de préciser
que ces accusations proviennent
de représentants du gouvernement américain,
de personnes au sein des médias loyales à ces différents gouvernements.
Je pense que la plupart des gens qui disent :
« Je ne crois pas que Snowden ait agi à cause de ses principes,
il doit avoir des raisons perverses et infâmes. »
en disent beaucoup plus sur eux-mêmes
que sur la cible de leurs accusations,
car... (Applaudissements)
ces personnes, celles qui émettent ces accusations,
agissent toujours en fonction de leurs intérêts corrompus.
Ils pensent donc que tout le monde est infesté
comme eux, par cette maladie qui est l'absence d'âme,
d'où leur hypothèse.
(Applaudissements)
BG : Merci beaucoup, Glenn. GG : Merci beaucoup.
BG : Glenn Greenwald.
(Applaudissements)